primed with sleeves rolled up there's an
election coming in case it's been
forgotten the third one in only four
years some new faces is the choice now
it's about who we are as a country as
well as more familiar ones pushing for
long sought-after goals at the start of
the race it's all slogan and little
policy and so this Wednesday Parliament
will once again be dissolved the MPs
pounding the streets persuading people
to vote for them and towering over this
of course is brexit with those wanting
to stop it battling those who want it
delivered and then there is the man that
didn't make it happen I didn't have to
as a matter of deep regret but what we
need to do now is get on and do it
despite a promise of do-or-die come what
may
Prime Minister Boris Johnson vowed he
wouldn't ask for the extension that
Parliament and the courts made him
request
despite rather colorfully saying that
he'd rather be dead in a ditch and the
politician snapping at his heels
promising to take the UK out without a
deal the brexit party's nigel farage
campaigning on a sole issue he will not
be standing but offered up the party's
backing to Johnson even though it was
roundly rebuffed Boris Johnson
whatsoever you know on this question of
Europe he's flipped and flopped a bit he
twice voted against the withdrawal
agreement he then voted for it so he's
shown his ability to change position and
now mr. Johnson is the time drop the
treaty and let's get on with the proper
breath and it's not just the UK breaking
away from Europe that's on the ballot in
Scotland where there is now 50% support
for independence it's also whether
belonging to the UK is a viable option
if brexit goes ahead
my friends the better alternative the
much better alternative for our country
is to take our future into our hands and
to become an independent country
the Conservatives may be ahead in the
polls but the party that sapped a number
of its MPs their one-time coalition
partner the Liberal Democrats their anti
brexit vision has persuaded moderate
pro-eu Tories to back them instead at
what of the main opposition Labour Party
leader jeremy corbyn's mixed messages
over brexit has left it significantly
behind the governing Conservatives
Corbin will seek to make this election
about issues such as the health service
raising taxes on the rich anything to
distract from the elephant in the room
but the problem for him
the others will likely make much of his
inability so far to come up with a clear
vision about where the party stands on
the matter which could leave it out in
the cold in this December election
sonica ago Al Jazeera London